you may have heard that there's a debate  going on tonight David Cameron has  chosen not to turn up to defend his  record this was a debate for the  opposition parties you will see in front  of you tonight the potential there is  for a coalition of chaos I'm being  invited I'm o fightin I'm not going to  try and get crush it what's your tactic  was nice my tactic oh to be sweet and  reasonable as always I don't want to be  part of any arrangement where we have to  dance to the tune of that man there is a  very real danger but Nigel Farage and  his friends could hold David Cameron to  ransom please can labour party MPs wear  red x I thought you know I would wear  one to match your top but next time I  promise you I'll be ready I'm wearing  red things as well it's just as good  seal right yes but to looking in real  life Oh quite what I expected  you